foreign
[Music]
things YouTube channel
um today I am going to be continuing my
documentary on the court system here in
the UK as you guys already know if you
watch the channel there are millions of
fathers every year that are estranged
from their children
um due to the court system not giving
men a fair shot in court
um so um during this series I've offered
that people can reach out to me if they
want to be a part of the documentary and
one of the people that reached out to me
was our guest today are James Jones
how'd you do uh welcome to the show so
tell me what made you want to reach out
to me today well I'm one of those uh
millions of fathers you mentioned a
second ago I I suspect my story is is a
little more extreme than most
a certain certainly very distressing
aspects of it
um I have not seen my son in two and a
half years
um an ongoing battle
uh legal battle for seven years
and
the the system is broken very badly
broken and I need to expose them and
this seems like the ideal opportunity to
me
so what do you say there's a lot of
people that say it's equally as bad for
men and for women that's not my
experience
certainly not there's many people that
say you're just going to be a one-off
there's not it's not that common I think
look I think that's uh
I think that's wishful thinking on
the part of the British public this
always happens to other people's
children right it never it's never going
to happen to your own
um the state cares right that's what
we're told
um they don't uh
feminism its most extreme form of
feminism has taken hold in a very bad
way
and we're seeing the results of that
in my case especially
so um I want to start I always start
with
how you met the mother of your child so
because a lot of the
the common you know complaint I get from
more conservative leaning people is that
you guys in the documentary should just
pick the right woman
and
um you know it's just you guys picking
bad women
so okay perhaps
um so I want to know
how you guys met first of all okay well
my my ex-wife is a Polish national
um she was uh
an economic uh migrant to Britain I
suppose and she worked in a hotel in
South Shropshire
a very rural traditional part of the
world
and uh this wasn't in a city certainly
not that's what they say it's just you
guys are picking city girls no no and
that's why okay so she's she was Polish
Polish so that's she is an Eastern
European background which is typically
good right very much so well this is I I
suspect there's there's an element and I
always felt this that
people would would think oh you've
chosen Eastern European woman because
she's going to do your bidding she's
going to behave cook and clean that sort
of thing
you you can't get along with English
women that couldn't be further from the
truth no really in my case Okay
um I can't speak for for all men
um but I've had
polish girlfriends I've had English
girlfriends
and um
really I I like to keep an open mind on
this sort of thing I
I didn't get to choose who I fell in
love with ultimately
and uh you know I was very much in love
with with my ex-wife at the time
I met her
you know I was just a local lad uh
simple kind of Farmer Boy who's made
good perhaps
um very rural area and I was out
drinking in a pub with my friends
in church Stratton
in the hills and she was drinking also
and we just hit it off it's as simple as
that and so you met her at a local pub
that's right she was a Polish girl
that's right yes she was quite a rural
uh girl as well in Poland she came from
a forestry background uh an idyllic part
of Poland is a truly beautiful place and
uh
and were her parents still together
no no okay
okay there had been a very messy divorce
there and he had been driven to
alcoholism
and it was um quite a tragic sight
really I I
got on with the in-laws
um they didn't speak English I didn't
really speak Polish I could order a beer
that's about it is and but we
we got on as as was best for all concern
but yeah sure there was there was a
history there of of divorce of I I just
asked because there's you know younger
men that watch the channel so I'm just
curious if there's like patterns in the
guys I interview of the win
ton to do this okay
um okay and you said that
um
you met her in the bar and then how when
did you guys get married what happened
next well that would be in 07 that we
met
um my she moved in to my flat in
Shrewsbury very soon after
um something of a whirlwind romance she
would later claim that I stalked her and
kind of
coerced her into living with me coerced
her into marriage and all this sort of
thing
um
clearly completely absurd that I would
be hanging around her place of work even
though she had invited me
um
quite distressing to think of it now
really it was a beautiful relationship
and and we fell in love with each other
it's as pure and simple as that
we um
at the time I was uh I had several jobs
I was a driving instructor I was
studying my degree
and I was an Army reservist as well and
it transpired that
there was an opportunity coming up for
me to go on to uh active service in
Afghanistan and it's something that I
developed to
an ambition for
um
my ex-wife was not keen on the idea at
all and she became quite distressed at
the at the thought of this there were
threats for her
uh going back to Poland leaving me Etc
a few weeks later she she became
pregnant
um
now I
like to think the best
of her I like I do like to believe her
but it did seem convenient at the time
and some may say that it was a
deliberate act to keep me from from
going and to ensure
a level of security perhaps because she
didn't want you to go and she did not
want me to go she's claimed that she had
changed her
contraceptive pill
I too I I still choose to believe that
myself
but really even now
honestly I choose to believe that but
but you don't really the truth may be
somewhat yeah more complex it's just
that's really convenient because you had
this job opportunity and you were
thinking about going she didn't want you
to go that's right and then she becomes
pregnant that's right
um okay so then what what happened when
she became pregnant well I immediately
maybe five minutes later asked her to
marry me as his customary of a gentleman
you might say and the way I've been
raised you felt like that was like the
right thing it's the right thing to do I
I still think to this day it was the
right thing to do
uh and we got married
um some months later in 2009
and uh my son came along in early 2010.
she was like a submissive wife no not at
all not at all this is uh
that this is not why I chose a Polish
woman she she seemed exotic to me she
made much of her
Noble ancestry that there was a certain
she was interesting
okay and not for the reasons
Manny might think
um
but she was
difficult she was stubborn and we
you know there was no
I think
right a lot is made of coercive control
right these days and I think she has
since claimed there was a high degree of
coercive control
um whatever it looks like and there was
not okay this was a normal relationship
where husband and wife
in the early days basically got on well
she gave birth she was a fantastic
mother okay
a great mother
um as time went on perhaps
and and pretty soon after she gave birth
really I would say that our relationship
cooled quite badly and
this was about how long after birth
that's what things switched pretty much
immediately right after the kid yeah now
I
I'm not naive I understand
a woman giving birth causes a great deal
of change in a woman and you would
expect this you'd expect her attention
to be fixed on a child as it was
quite right too
but
but not at the antipathy of myself not
at the clear blind hatred of myself
um all kind of
intimacy stopped
we would intimate moments twice a year
at the very most
you would have sex twice a year yeah
wow so she had the kid and then the sex
stopped yeah okay yeah
um
and how long did you go on like that
um for six years
wow so you had sex with your wife wife
twice a year for six years yes did you
ever step out did you ever cheat
not until the end I suppose and even
then I didn't actually cheat I was
eventually I suppose I mean that's
that's essentially I think that's like
starving a guy yeah yeah I mean it is
isn't it
um and any kind of normal relationship
between man and wife yeah requires
intimacy whatever that looks like okay
sexual whatever emotional yeah
um
but there was none and for a normal
red-blooded male like myself it was a
source of frustration I don't I don't
you can't hide that fact at all twice a
year like that's mad yeah yeah okay yeah
it's still recovering from it yeah
yeah because essentially she gets so she
gets the
what she wants which is like a child she
gets the security but men need sex yeah
of course so you're essentially starving
a guy up so like what is he supposed to
do some may say women need sex as well
but I didn't see it was she was she
cheating at all
I don't think so okay because like my
head is like if she's not sleeping with
you
right okay
um sorry this is just how I think but no
no I I think that would be
no I I don't think she did but
it wouldn't surprise me if she did I in
the end I was
caught
I suppose you could say
um a woman I had met through work had
texted me a few times I texted back
and just the attention of a woman
just a woman had noticed me and had
found me attractive and she wanted to
flirt with me yeah I flirted back sure
I didn't actually meet this this woman
any further I had no intention I was
I was stuck in a sexless Loveless
relationship but but my son
right my son was everything to me he
stole everything to me to this day and
really in my mind I was thinking well
how long can I go
can I
can I continue this to my son is 16 18.
right how long do I last in this
relationship for my son's sake
and really she took that option away
when she found this text message and I
said well what was the text message
um no just as I said earlier that it was
just learning a fairly innocent flirt
but you never met uh never I didn't I'd
met her previously in a professional way
but I didn't meet up I didn't meet her
up I wouldn't even blame you if you did
to be honest I have weird views on this
stuff but
um okay so at this point you're having
sex twice a year if that
um you have your son and you're thinking
how how long can I do this for that's
right yeah essentially wrong
um okay and how do you think you would
have stuck it out for your son
even if it continued like that
hindsight we're talking about right
um had I known then what I know now
that's a very good question but all the
pain and anguish that my son has gone
through
I'd have to say I would probably stick
it out because my son is being so
damaged by this that my my needs a
secondary to that I can
I would have lived like a monk for
for much longer
um
yeah it's just been so catastrophic to
my son that you'd never predict this at
the time I I just assumed when we split
that we come to some sort of amical
agreement that
obviously me me and her would stay
friends because although okay look
I hope I'm not painting a picture of a
completely miserable existence me and
her remain friends although the physical
sexual aspect of our relationship had
long since died we could go out we could
have good times as three of us
we were pretty good unit
two of us me and my me and my wife
no there was nothing there
so
turning the clock back yeah I would have
enjoyed
to save my son from this
so
um she found the texts and then what
happened
I
every
every part of my soul was
just tell me just Escape just get out
just take the opportunity the
opportunity there to escape and my son
was it was a time of great in a turmoil
that
all about my son
you know and and I sold myself
the story that actually
I'd become a better father
afterwards you know if I'd find a
different woman
I would become more
complete my whole
I wouldn't be so miserable I'd be happy
and
my son would
would benefit from that
that's not how it turned out
very soon after
maybe a few weeks after okay so did
after what oh after the tax after I left
okay so you left sorry yes I did leave
and uh basically I was told to leave
by my ex-wife okay she told you to leave
yes okay she told me to leave and I left
there were
sounds rather clear-cut now there were
times where
she wants me back she didn't I wanted to
come back I didn't you know there's a
period of like back and forth yeah am I
doing the right thing you know and uh
eventually yes I left and
but look
it wasn't
my ex helped me out with the furniture
right she
said oh you can have this I'll I'll keep
that and she was actually you know I got
the van and she was actually helping me
live French into the van you know there
wasn't I thought okay this is awkward
this is
painful but this is going to settle down
because we can do this together we can
be friends we can surely
do the best for my son
and
a few weeks transpired and
trying to make arrangements to see my
son became more and more difficult over
these these two or three weeks
um just
initially she was inviting me to their
home
cooking dinner for me
I would take my son out playing whatever
you know play tennis at local
courts or playing on a trampoline all
sorts we'd do I even taught him to ride
his bike during that time
and um
it just got more and more fraught that
the phone calls are being ignored text
messages were being ignored more and
more cryptic messages were coming back
just simple things like I want to I want
to see my son today
yeah he wants to see me Etc is this this
is normal and she'd say yeah yeah no
problems come and collect him do what
you like and then closer today
oh he doesn't want to
this isn't him this is you don't want
him to
no no he doesn't want to go
can we rearrange for some other day and
I say well no hang on I've arranged this
day
and
I I it made me upset it made everybody
upset because this was just deliberate
deliberate problems deliberate hurdles
being put in our way and um
yeah eventually it came to a point where
I did manage that the final time I did
manage to pick him up with my mother in
her in her van
um
we went for a little picnic we didn't
have time to do the the activities I had
in mind is getting quite late in the day
and I went to pick him up I was we're in
a rush I don't deny that we picked him
up because
time was getting short it was getting
quite late in the evening I said look
I'll I'll bring him back at
such a Time eight o'clock was it
taking for a little picnic up a Hill
Called Longmont which is a large kind of
expansive Wilderness and service rupture
and uh yeah me and my son my mother had
a wonderful time I had a picnic
a bit of Tom Foolery you know
called him back as arranged to be met by
one of my ex's darling friends
um
Emily s I'll say her name
and this is a woman
known for creating trouble amongst other
families
known to the Social Services known
for causing strife
with her own ex-partner creating stories
about him
she'd even um
she'd go around deliberately boasting
she'd flooded her own house so that you
could claim on insurance and she got a
holiday out of it all new
so she was known around town as somebody
who yeah
Village I was supposed to say a very
small rural community okay known as a
real Arch Troublemaker someone my
ex-wife had
had become actually
she was friendly but then she had
told her to keep a distance because we
she'd even my ex-wife didn't want her
right before we split up after we split
up it was a different story so after you
split up she spent more time around this
Emily s girl Emily SPS that's right SPS
okay and she basically and she's known
for having false allegations against her
ex-husband that's absolutely yeah okay
yes so this is something she's known for
and
okay so essentially
what so you you take your son on the
picnic what happens next well
we arrived back it's my ex-wife's home
uh my son's home
and uh Emily ASP is there right she's
just waiting on the side of the road and
in this very small village very rural
road Hedges very high Hedges just about
wide enough for one car
that sort of thing and she's there
and
wind down the window and say hello Emily
what are you doing here
um not I have no idea what's going on
and uh she said well
she doesn't want to see you the iron to
take your son off off you I said well
that's not right is it
where is where is she I want to hand my
son over to my
my ex-wife as is normal
no no can't do that
okay
so
I try my best to ignore her and just get
out of the van and take some gets out
the van and try attempt to
take take him towards the house he he
was carrying some
some things some paper and some toys
that I'd given him and this this woman
Emily grabbed at him
grabbed by his almonds and drag dragged
him away
from my from his grandmother my mother
he dropped his things he started crying
dragged him into the house
got a mobile phone all right so I'm
going to call the police I'm going to
call the police right
me and my mother absolutely dumbstruck
right the allegation being that
previously I'd walked into the house
Uninvited to get his jacket I'd already
been in the house five minutes
previously so we've got my son out of
the house we put him in the van oh your
jacket we forgot your jacket
now I've been invited to that house only
a few days previously I just right I run
it opened the door get the jacket out we
come the allegation was that I opened
the door into my ex-wife's face
and started shouting at her of course
it's all rubbish
and
anyway that was the allegation that
came my way later
that was the story anyway so me and my
mother
dumbfounded what on Earth is this
we thought
we've got to go and see the police and
just
make them aware I don't want to start
throwing allegation I just make them
aware of the situation because this this
seems eyes of order this is escalating
out of our control
so that's what we did we went to the
police station we filed a child related
incident
and really that was that for a few days
and then at work I worked at
Wolverhampton University as a
sort of a
lecture type of person I suppose and um
one day it's huge
envelope right
a couple of inches thick Maybe
thud straight on my desk
I thought you know what on Earth is this
I opened it and
started reading just allegation after
allegation after all I get just false
allegations
our mother station being made X party
all right so that is basically a court
order
against me approaching her or my son
without me even knowing about it okay
20 or 30 false allegations you name it
coercive control abuse
very few actual incidents
mentions just tick box oh yes he
coercively controlled me well where you
know what what example are you referring
to non-give okay
I I was absolutely dumbfounded
what what hope is this I start ringing
around solicitors they start giving me
these horrific quotes
tens of thousands of pounds money I
didn't have
and
just the the hopelessness that of the
picture they were painting was
distressing
anyway I'm rabbiting on a bit so that's
so you you were
basically given a big pile of papers
with all these false allegations where
they would sort of spin
stories into coercive control so they
would say like when you said earlier
that she moved in that like they made it
seem like you forced her to move in or
you were waiting around her words yes
and so they just said like basically the
last couple of years in your
relationship it's all spun yes exactly
right as a control okay exactly right
Financial control
was another well can you list all of the
controls or like all of the abuse or
that she accused you of financial
coercive
I mean that's it really I mean Financial
abuse uh you know domestic abuse abuse
domestic violence okay okay she had
um accused me of throwing a wardrobe
draw at my son okay
now what had actually transpired was
nothing of the sort
what happened okay this was a this was
an argument there's no doubt that this
is an argument what happened is she
this is six months before which splits
up as well so she had
she was going into local town to do some
shopping
I had my
my car my Jaguar all right I've always
been a classic car man I had no money
but this this counted as a family car
right and this is my one kind of
pleasure in life I suppose
and I said oh take the keys off you go
you know use the car it's there because
we all enjoy it now
um
she had her own car
just enjoy the jackets it's there for
all of us
and uh I I watched her get in the car
put my son in the child's seat and I
watched her reverse a very small
driveway she was reversing clearly
towards the fence
oh she's got that wrong she's going to
reverse into the fence so I ran out of
the house I said please stop please stop
the car you're going to reverse into the
fence
um you know do it like this sort of
thing
kept going kept going into the fence
what are you doing why have you reversed
you know scratch the back end also what
are you doing
and you could see that her becoming
hysterical what what's what are you
doing this for sure she drives forward
and then she reverses into the fence
again
and I'm getting pretty irate by now then
she drives forward and then she reverses
into the fence again
and then she she shot off forward of a
pile of rocks of card Banks my son's in
the car at the time but this is insane
this wasn't now you know there's no
reason for us anyway she can comes back
half an hour later I'm pretty angry but
I would say justifiably so
and I told my I told it look just leave
me alone for a while okay
um I'm gonna have to calm down you
probably want to leave me alone
because she starts following me
throughout the house and screaming at me
and she won't leave me alone and I'm
for some reason I have to change my
clothes or whatever I'm looking in the
wardrobe and I get frustrated I pull a
wardrobe by a wardrobe drawer out and I
let it fall to the floor
and pretty childish I I mean not abuse
not not thrown at anyone yeah not
directed at her or anyone else it's like
any anything you to respond at all they
just say oh look there's abuse but they
don't talk about like what started it no
well the point is that and and it wasn't
for you Stephen begin with no that's not
abuse yeah
that's not abuse that that is there's
something I regret something I apologize
for something pretty dumb silly what
happens immediately
do you think how long ago was that from
when she gave you the papers six months
before do you think she was planning
this
because if she if she has like a
documents this big I would think that
she'd basically been taking notes yeah I
would go along with that I think there
was a there was a a build up towards
this now what had happened
as you straight away
my son was in the room adjacents and I
remember this very clearly that she went
he was aware of this of what had gone on
but she went got my son brought him in
and started shouting at me that I'd
thrown the drawer at him there and then
right
I thought what he wasn't even in the
room then she starts then she walked up
to me and started hitting me as hard as
she could I I restrained her I said look
please just calm down right you
scratched my car it's not the end of the
world that's just calm down
and um
I was kind of taken aback by that and I
thought this is this is odd six months
before
we then had
my son being
he'd always known how to speak Polish
and I of course I encouraged it I was
trying to learn it myself
and I was very proud of his
Polish ancestry I love Poland why not
but she would um
start to abuse me in Polish so I didn't
know what she was saying and she would
train my son to swear at me in Polish
all right and I and he and he would
laugh at me right stupid ass
Daddy's a stupid ass in you know
Daddy's a [__] so yes that's
correcting yeah I remember that and and
my son
laughing was this while you were
together yeah this this was during the
last six months really I suppose and it
was just an hour so while you were still
together she was teaching her son to
swear at you yes yeah look it's not it
started as a joke right I'm I've got a
pretty well developed sense of humor I
can take the piss I can I can laugh at
myself that's fine
but it there comes a point where jokes
stop being jokes it's disrespectful and
it becomes disrespect and hatred so
you get the abuse document
um and was that the last time you saw
your son the picnic
for six months yes okay so what what
happened after you got those documents
she wouldn't let you see them no without
what
so a she had approached Family Court
um Emily ESP had taken her to see her
solicitor right
and she bragged about this to my mother
I've taken her to see my solicitor
because my mother had approached the
house dropped drop dropped off gifts of
course the police
were accosting my my mother
threatening her
not to approach she had no reason you
know there's nothing there's no reason
why my my mother can't can't see her
grandson
you know
and um
so we have the magistrates court
involved we have kafkas become involved
um ass calf Karen can you tell them what
calf curse is well it's a kind of I
forget the entire acronym but it's the
court advisory service
um
to do with family matters
so early on typically you'll have
magistrates court involved a magistrator
lay justices they they're not
specialists
they are members of the community group
and uh
kafkas will do some very basic
investigations interview
myself my ex
and
give advice to the court on that basis
and this took six months
for them to really pull their finger out
and do their job
and I was met with a kafkas officer
uh Andrea ashinazi she came from Romania
really someone who didn't want to listen
to a single word I had to say at all I'd
since moved into a very small little
terraced house
she came to visit me I was looking
forward to it I was looking forward can
we just I want to make sure I understand
so you get the documents and this is at
the six month Mark half cast finally
comes yeah something like that yeah so
and you hadn't seen your son in the time
yeah yeah and so they're supposed to
investigate the situation
and you had to basically she wouldn't
let you see your son
and you had to wait for six months for
kafkas to come yes and you thought this
was going to be good
because you thought you were going to
get a fair yeah yeah questionnaire
that's right but then they send this
woman and she essentially doesn't care
what you have to say she doesn't give a
damn no and what was what was her name
Andrea shanazi Andreas schnauzy okay and
she um
her attitude
towards me now look I appreciate there
are many families in this situation now
I've always I've always thought that
maybe they are troubled families they
come from
you know their own benefits they're
alcoholics they're on drugs whatever and
we have areas like that in in Shropshire
and I dare say these people are used to
dealing with families of that kind
and that's certainly the way I was
treated like
you know first question one of the first
how much alcohol are you consuming
so what what has this Got to Do with It
you know there was an assumption I must
be alcoholic no I don't have a little
bit of beer I'm a real ailment right
um
just a whole attitude towards me was one
of yours aren't I you know we're here to
sort you out
and
I I was just left pulled and
my instinct was to say well
no I'm not that person I'm this person
I'm kind of successful I'm a chartered
engineer I I'm a good father my son
loves me I've got all these photographs
now
don't want to see photographs right
she explained to me that children could
be made to smile in photographs
so they won't even look at them so I had
a huge diet you know huge book of
photographs ready to show it look this
is me and my son having a good time is
it this is my son and my mother having a
good time
it's there you can't deny this she
didn't even want to see them she'd
already made her mind up she'd already
seen been to see my ex-wife there was
clearly kindred spirit
that both Eastern European both
and she just believed every last
allegation she said as fact no word of
no doubt at all so she's coming in
getting the interview from you and it's
very biased so what what happens after
that
well it goes back to the magistrates
Court
um I have to essentially accept the
uh the non-molar station order okay so
for financial reasons I can't afford it
and she did that immediately like the
six months ago that's right ex-party
which means I wasn't even aware
like chart so restraining order
I know it's the non-mala station order
here then Kafka says to get involved and
make a report that's right yes and then
after calf Cass
then it goes back to the court it does
yes okay and then did you ever get an
actual day day in court yes I was
several days in court but but these um
magistrates call early on sometimes I
had representation I managed to afford
uh a a barrister it was horrifically
expensive and really I ended up how much
did you spend well it was like five
thousand pound just for two or three
appearances okay so you spent about five
thousand pounds and
to begin with yes and just I'm sorry to
keep and in this time you you've been
kicked well you willingly left your home
but she was in the family home that's
right yeah okay so she's in that
um were you still paying for the family
home
not at that stage no financially
the financials have always perplexed me
because I I made an offer I I did the
right thing I approached the um
the agency I forget the name of the
agency for child maintenance and I
filled in the forms and they gave me a
figure
for how much I was expected to
contribute to her
and this is in the six month period yes
okay so how much so oh so on top of that
you're paying child support too
well well this was the form that
suggested how much I should be paying to
my ex-wife for child support and I was
happy with the figure it was something
in the region of three or four hundred
pounds a month so not a huge sum
and I said well and I I presented that
to her solicitor
they denied they ever received it
and they denied
and this is part of the financial
control thing that they repeatedly
ignored
the truth that I was happy to pay that
but she clearly didn't she clearly
didn't want it she she would rather
pretend I didn't do that so that she
could accuse me of financial control so
she has never actually accepted any
money from me
which is unusual for these cases okay
all right
and this
really reveals her motives to be quite
extreme that it was more a case of
she wants to
serve at all ties with me Financial
a lot because she probably wanted to
return to Poland with my son that was
that was not stated but that seemed to
be pretty obvious to me
wow so so you think her goal was to
several times so she could go back yeah
initially okay I don't have any doubt
about that
um okay so in this time period you're
paying the lawyers
um you don't you're not on child support
but you're not in your family home so
you had to figure out housing otherwise
that's right yes yeah so then you get
your day in court what happens well I
represent myself mostly
um so I am
I
[Music]
um
pretty clueless about the
about what happens I'm Guided by the the
clerk of the court
um
but really it's just a it's just a kind
of Kangaroo Court they've made their
mind up well before they'd receives all
the reports and there's actually very
little to say openly in court I decided
to cross-examine the kafkas officer
[Music]
um
my tone was not
welcomed it was said well this is not a
a criminal court Mr Jones I said well
are we worried about the truth you know
apparently not
um so what did you cross-examine her on
well just the the findings she'd made
against me uh and um
that the way she'd basically accepted
all of my ex-wives
uh
uh allegations without any
without any question
there was no evidence back backing up
and I would ask her what evidence do you
have for this
and she the question was was we're kind
of rejected are we not allowed to ask
that Mr Jones what evidence they would
have for the abuse yeah well it won't
there was not yeah but like the alleged
abuse exactly so you kept asking them
what evidence they haven't so they have
no evidence at this point no one
whatsoever at any point ever okay so
then what what do they conclude in court
the
really
I was to be thrown into the Dustbin as a
father for no real reason
that I had to the only
the only thing I I really accepted
because look there was a huge pressure
right from the beginning right from the
outset for me to accept
responsibility for things I hadn't done
right
why aren't you accepting that this is
truth why why don't you share
responsibility Mr John I said because
this didn't happen I'm not an abusive
person I'm a great father
etc etc
they made me do an anger management
course which was kind of ridiculous
in time with no evidence no evidence
okay
anger management
okay in time I did manage to see
my son
they had arranged uh meetings at uh
child contact centers
this went on on and off for
around 18 months
how often were you able to see him once
a month once every few weeks something
like that okay
um I I made a further application
at which point
a
things were taken more seriously so my
son was appointed a child a legal
guardian uh kafkas at higher up than a
CAF gas officer and a district judge was
appointed uh District Judge McQueen
and many more
reports were written
many more allegations were made by my ex
this dragged on and on and on for
years until eventually
well eventually I did get
a shared parenting order
after
almost well how long would that be three
years of
private Law Court battles
but things had happened in the meantime
that um
I should probably start talking about
okay
so just I'm going to get to that but the
Shared Parenting order that was
um so you did this for three years you
had to take an anger management course
yes
you had to do you only got to see your
son once a month
um for a child contact centers which
those are essentially just to make sure
I have it right they're centers that
it's like for abusive parents right yeah
because it's like saying you can't be
trusted to have the kids so you have to
see about a child contact center it it
was just appalling yeah and essentially
they have no evidence that you abused
your son
that's absolutely right okay
okay and
um when you got the Shared Parenting
orders that 50 50
not quite
um I it's kind of the norm for this
country where I would have him for every
other weekend
um every Wednesday and half of all
school holidays and the weekend started
Friday evening and ended Monday morning
where I we we were not to have
we weren't initially to
to
I was not initially to take my son
to his mother uh it was seen as easy if
we took him to school and picked him up
from school so we didn't have any direct
contact
which was fair enough
okay but the three years that's where
um I know you mentioned there's like
more to the story so that's when the
crazy stuff happened there's a there's a
hell of a lot more
um
this is when the tragedy of Archie
Spriggs becomes
a significant
that
Archie Springs okay so for people that
don't know who is Archie Springs Archie
Spriggs was my son's best friend and he
was murdered by his mother
in
forgive me 2017.
and um
yeah
anyway
um I should probably start at the
beginning with that but um
that
before me and my ex split up
um we were we had become aware of Leslie
Speed and her son Archie Spriggs who had
moved into the raspberry neighborhood
Leslie is that the woman from earlier is
that someone else no this is this is
Archie springs's mother this is not
Emily asked this is okay but this is
another very similar character from the
from the neighborhood okay Leslie Speed
mostly speed okay
so
we had um
we'd become aware that they'd entered
the
neighborhood
um some years before actually Archie was
quite naughty
um it was known that she'd come from a
deprived background in kind of a rough
area of a local town
and Social Services had basically moved
them into the neighborhood
as you to kind of separate them from
that lifestyle too
to reform them really it was known
inverted commas that she had been
abused by um Archie's father
that's certainly the story that was spun
for us now we were Good Samaritans we
saw ourselves as pillars of the
community and we said well yeah of
course we'll help out
we'll
we will invite them into our community
but
we'll keep them in arms length Okay
because there's clearly problems that
that was my kind of take on it and that
was my ex-wife's take on it
as time went on Archie's Behavior
improved he became a lovely little that
I like to think my son had something to
do with that that he'd befriended him
my son was quite a good influence on him
and Archie became lovely and uh
used to enjoy him coming around to play
and
all that sort of thing
and that's before we we kind of split up
and then we we split up then
Emily ASP and Leslie Speed both became
kind of thorns in our side really that
uh we'd we'd we'd been asked and
encouraged to rushbury school to see
things like sports day and to get
involved in in school functions
um but Leslie Speedway these women and
others and other mothers would kind of
kind of Shepherd
my son away from us
may my mother others in my family would
approach would approach him
they'd all kind of present a wall of
mothers between us and him Spirit him
away
between you and Archie between me and my
son between you and yourself so you
would try to speak to your son and then
these group of mothers came together
that's right yes okay very much so and
and that included the Archie's mom which
is Leslie yeah and the other lady and
then Emily so
Leslie Emily and your ex-wife okay
that's right and others and others but
and even
School teachers
female School teachers kind of were
negative there was a it was a wall of
negativity against us
presented from these these women
and
things started getting kind of
ridiculous that
the the type of allegations made against
me be got more and more ridiculous
instances became more and more
ridiculous the thing that sticks out in
my mind really was that my son had
broken his arm at a a play
in a soft Play Place
and I'd become aware nobody actually
told me but I'd become aware
and I wanted to go and see him in
hospital and
Comfort my son
um
it was said by Emily ASP that
that
um
my ex-wife had requested an armed guard
to be put on duty in the hospital
so that I would not be able to go and
see
right
then some
some weeks later I mean I'd occasionally
send text messages to to my ex-wife
usually on the lines of how is my son
doing when can you know
can we not please make some progress
please you know all helpful all
supported
13 over a six-month period now I was
arrested by the police
and
thrown into a cell questioned only later
did the police actually read the text
messages
and and they were arrested for texting
her yes 13 over six months
13 texts over six months and that was
with the non-molest because of the
non-molesterol no the non-molestation
order actually lapsed by that point so
there was nothing stopping me
so there's no reason you couldn't text
her legal
but she just had you thrown in jail and
the police complied yeah yeah it was if
look if a woman says it's harassment
it's harassment right what would the
police say like why if I had a police
office
why would they come
because
I suspect like my best friends as a
police officer and I suspect that they
would say that she is seen as a
vulnerable adult that she has made
certain allegations
and so she is put on a kind of short
list or an asterisk is put next to her
name so whenever she makes an allegation
then things happen very quickly she's
taken very seriously
um
but you know the police is
pretty competent you know they
they arrested me and only then did they
think to read these text messages I mean
this isn't this obviously the wrong way
around but the first thing you do oh and
allegations to be made let's get him put
him in in a cell and then we'll bother
doing our job right
so only a few weeks later I I was told
by my girlfriend at the time that oh
there's a boy
being murdered being murdered
and they're showing
the road that your son lives on so I
look in a near local paper and I I say
oh my God
and knowing the kind of allegations it's
getting more and more
you know I'd punched her in my sleep
once apparently you know just this
the allegations are getting crazier just
crazy and crazy and uh do you think she
like was convinced like I I wonder do
you think the
crew yeah I think she'd she'd tricked
herself into thinking they were true
after a while she started believing her
own lives there's no doubt I think she
does to this day that she had
constructed this fantasy world where I
was some sort of
you know she she was meeting
um
he's kind of woman's age Charities these
group meetings in the local town
that was known
um other mothers in the area were
actually part of this group
um if you how do you because I was
thinking could I could I go to a woman's
Aid place like would they can anyone
just go to one any woman can yes yes I
was curious what they would you know if
like I said I was someone abused me
they're not going to question you
they're not going to they're not going
to assume you're lying they're going to
assume you're telling the truth
they're then typically going to give you
advice
they're going to tell you what to say
and how to present
and it's going to be a game of top
trumps right between
you know you you all sat there in your
circle I you know my ex did that no my
ex did something worse no my ex did
something worse and it just becomes this
kind of echo chamber yeah that
everything gets gets more and more
extreme more and more hysterical
Okay so
okay so you found out that your son's
best friend was murdered yeah well I
thought it was actually my son murdered
at the time so I
I phoned my ex-wife I sent text messages
she refused to answer even then even at
that point
she just didn't want to engage
at all
and uh it was well into the net you know
I'd phoned the police and asked
is this my son
unfortunately you know sounds Dreadful
to say that no but
the relief was it wasn't him
I only
I only really heard anything from my
ex-wife well into the next day
well why why can't you just
Let It Go something something truly
terrible has happened it transpired that
my ex-wife was very close friends with
Leslie Speed
and that
her and my son and Leslie Archie would
frequently go out playing and they'd
been out the day before
so I believe my ex-wife was the last
person to see Archie alive
and
clearly within this group and I like you
know
I later found out from for Matthew
Spriggs that's you know I don't speak
for Matthew Spriggs by the way
the father of Archie but
you know he'd experienced much the same
as I had that there were groups of women
hurling abuse at him
unnecessary abuse really vile
you know mobile phones are taking
photographs you know films of him
picking his son up dropping the sun back
shouting and swearing at him with the
children and my son included so this is
my ex amongst this group of women
throwing hurling abuse at him
yeah this is this is days before Leslie
Speed did what she did
so
she smothered and strangled him
and
it transpires it seems that this was
there were two reasons really that that
it was a way to prevent Archie ever
being looked after by
Matthew and it was also an act of
revenge against Matthew
and the similarities of the kind of
allegations she was making against him
mirrored almost exactly
the allegations my ex is making it
against me these are two women
maybe a third with Emily asp
ECT you know saying and doing the same
things and following a very similar a
similar pattern a similar very similar
pattern
and I you know before this the point is
before his murder before this murdered I
had picked up on this and I'd warned
uh Kafka so the local Authority Social
Services were not involved at this point
I should add but I had stated very
clearly that I was very concerned by
this group of women
the the behavior is becoming
kind of a group Hysteria
and that something needs to be done so
some of them needed to look into this
Behavior because it's getting spiraling
out of control and my fear was something
was going something would snap something
was going to happen I had no idea we're
going to be that serious or anything
like that and I'm certainly not accusing
my ex-wife of any culpability in this
you know she's not responsible we know
who's responsible
but
this kind of group think amongst this
group of women
it's a dangerous thing
it can have real consequences
and it can have the most terrible
consequences and perhaps rather than
encouraging women like Leslie Speed who
was had known kind of homicidal
tendencies
probably not known to my ex-wife but
surely it is better to try to defuse
these situations
it's better to say look that's these
let's just calm down let's try and do
the best we can for our children let's
let's not throw these wild allegations
around but by hyping everything up by
making everything more and more extreme
then some people will snap
and she certainly did why why did she
strangle her son she did it because she
didn't want the dad
so she strangled her did she say that or
how did that there is evidence
in the murder trial that seems to
suggest that she's written a letter
um
that explained that
you know that it seemed to be an act of
revenge against him wow and that um
at least you know I'm sorry
I forget the exact wording and I would
kind of need to get that right
so I don't want to go into too many
details on that but
it was an actual Revenge
against the father okay
and she was making all of the same
allegations against him as my ex was
making against me they were a very
tight-knit group of mothers the children
were all very close friends
they were links that I had seen I become
very concerned but of course
whenever I raised my concerns well Mr
Jones you're not allowed to say who your
ex-wife can and can't be friends with
that's coercive control you're
controlling your ex-wife
look my ex-wife can make whatever
friends she likes but when when they
become involved with my son
and these are women are kind of
babysitting my son influencing my son
then I I have surely have a right to
become concerned and I can't help but
think that my concerns were completely
and utterly justified by what happened
that I was making these noises before
this happened or anything happened and
it seemed that Matthew Spriggs was
independent I didn't know the man really
I'd only met him once but I later found
out he was making these noises as well
that he was complaining against
obviously his ex partner Leslie Speed
but he was noticing the behavior of this
group of women other my other people in
the neighborhood might one of my oldest
friends
I mean before it becomes so serious that
she would kind of laughingly joke oh
yeah I know the group of those group of
women they're the husband haters that's
what we call that
um you know it sounds tragic now
at the time it was kind of seen as
light-hearted and then that happened
and um
so what we have is obviously the social
services we're involved with
with Archie Springs that they they
weren't involved with our case at that
time
we were still in the private law Realm
but
it's private law that's family court yes
I mean the family cause also gets
involved Public Law Public Law is
basically when a local Authority will
act will want to take a child into care
that becomes public law
and so
typically
everybody is funded down through legal
aid I was not funded through Legal Aid
at all at like at least
private law stage my ex-wife was because
she had a box to tick right she there
was a box saying are you subject to
domestic abuse
tick no further questions all right yeah
it will give you legal aid so so she
never had to represent herself she never
had to learn the ins and outs of family
law like like I did never had to stand
up in court
pretend to be some sort of barrister
but so you know maybe 20 30 Court
appearances mostly rubbish mostly time
wasted
over this this period where she was
funded she had barristers I had no no
such thing um
so she did she go to jail the mother of
Archie yes okay so she actually did she
went to prison for that but the the sad
part was that there was warnings about
this
yes and like from you from the dad yes
and nothing was done nothing was done
and if anything you guys were looked at
as the abusers to this day I would say
there are people who see Leslie Speed as
a victim
to this day even though she's done what
she's done
that there are still people I I who
would still see
Mr Spriggs as an abuser and Leslie Speed
as a victim and she
those more extreme feminists will see
her as well this is what happens when
you commit death monastic abuse against
a woman
she's got an excuse
fortunately it's not a viewer held by
the majority of the public
certainly not a view held by me that is
an evil woman
a very evil woman
and yes like you say
um there were warnings there were
warning signs that were not heated but
in the serious case for view in the
inquest that was held some years later
the findings were made that
the death could not be avoided
well
had you listened to Mr Spriggs all you
had to do is listen to him
all you had to do was listen to me and
and look at these cases
and the links between them
I was only ever told that oh we only
have a look at cases in isolation
well how can you when there's there's
clearly a an environment in which this
is going on as groups of women
there are they gossip they
you know they do what women do you might
say which is obviously
not very politically there were plenty
of opportunities but they I believe it
was a whitewash
that they didn't want to confront the
truth of their failures in the local
authorities Shropshire Council Social
Services
but the the main finding made by at the
inquest John Ellery the
the coroner for Shropshire
um suggested but recommended that uh
the local Authority should intervene
earlier in such cases
that
that essentially take more children into
Care at an earlier stage
now on the very day that he made that uh
yes okay yes that would be foster care
okay
so the coroner looks at Archie's case
and says that like foster care should
intervene quicker yes okay in in similar
cases
so then that made them look at your son
exactly okay and this was this happened
he died in 2017 so when was this
well
he'd made that would be 2019. okay so he
made that recommendation in the meantime
in the meantime there had been some
movement that me and my son had a Shared
Parenting Agreement we 20 the end of
2018 2019
was wonderful for me and my son we'd
finally got the the time together that
we needed we did all sorts we went on
Holiday Island Dorset and
I can't even begin you know there were
so many things that we did together we
went camping because around this time so
around this time you
you'd gotten the Shared Parenting
Agreement finally from the court that's
right and so but that took three years
to get yeah essentially essentially yeah
and you didn't see your son so five
years has gone by total around this
point
I believe I have this three years sorry
that uh but I thought I thought there
was a year or two you didn't see how he
had there was yeah that was 2016 2017. I
didn't really see in 2018 things
improved slightly but we were working up
to February 2019 where we had a final
court order which gave us a formal
shared parenting yeah so I'm saying
total this has been like five years at
that point four or five four five four
five years ago okay and so I just like
to get the timeline right so four or
five years now things are better with
your son you get to see him every other
weekend that's right yeah so but then
Archie dies and they finally come to a
conclusion on that case that foster care
needs to intervene sooner yes well we
had to share Parenting Agreement as far
as my family concerned myself my son
obviously is the most important player
here
my son had a had the relationships he
needed but however my ex-wife continued
to make problems continue to create
stumbling blocks she was not attending
any of the meetings the child in need
meetings that were required
so six months went by we were supposed
to have child in need meetings where
basically air issues and we are supposed
to
come to agreements and things are
supposed to settle down and this is
supposed to take
three months
and
the court Social Services who were
involved at that point leave us alone to
get on with it okay that's the theory
and that was what was ordered by the
court
six months goes past and not one meeting
has taken place we're supposed to these
are supposed to be fortnightly
right so
eventually
you know
we have this this thing
and you're probably well aware of this
parental alienation okay now this is
a process where
a
parent
and I'm going to say typically a mother
as has been my experience and most
experiences I've heard of
uh mothers who will
basically trash the reputation of the
Father by sometimes those subtle means
sometimes they're very obvious means now
my ex-wife was clearly committing this
sort of thing she'd put up security
cameras bristling all over her house she
was clearly hoping to catch me
um
you know my my son was aware of
everything going on around him he was
old enough to understand what was going
on okay
and she was creating more and more of
these problems well what happened in the
end on the very day
well actually sorry I'm jumping ahead a
little bit we did actually eventually
have one child in need meeting
chaired by a social worker Gail
mowington he was completely inept
and we had eight people sat in the room
at a local school
now this is supposed to be a private
kind of family meeting
right but there were two police officers
invited
the implication being that I'm obviously
going to start beating people up
we've got several School teachers we've
got my ex-wife we've got a new friend
who is a militant feminist who is
invited in
who's supposed to be there just for
emotional support for mine for my
ex-wife okay as myself there's several
other
kind of social workers
but what this descends into instead of
this this kind of uh constructive
um conversation it's supposed to be it
becomes a slanging match everybody takes
in turns to criticize me and say well
your son
presents as scared he presents as he's
always very untidy whenever you drop him
off he's always late he's always tired
he he never wants to talk about his
father he was seemed scared about his
father this just runs contrary to
everything I knew about about my son I
was explaining look this isn't real
you know that this is how does that
happen do you think your wife just told
them stories and they believed it yes
but it was well known my my ex-wife
spent far too much time around the
school making friends with teachers
telling them stories that weren't true
making my son seem like a victim when he
was not
uh and making everybody feel sorry for
him when he was just a normal lad okay
and he was becoming quite happy really
that we had finally got a situation
where he got to have a dad and a
grandmother and a grandfather and all my
side the family were all
you know aunts and uncles that sort of
thing and he was becoming quite happy
okay
this this meeting descended into chaos
and
I I kind of walked out
because I could see it was a hatchet job
and
so the meeting collapsed essentially
this
this friend of my ex-wife who who seems
I believe she's something to do with the
women's Aid group a clear Mill isn't
feminists started asking me questions
and what what writers she to ask me
questions in a meeting that's
she has nothing she's there for
emotional support nothing else
and that was very typical of the sort of
thing that happened anyway a few days
later I I got to see myself
my son was extremely upset
and uh
he told me that
mummy told me to say bad things about
you because it made her happy
which is about this clear-cut case
because my son would we never discuss
things like this it was not something
I wanted to burden my son with I mean of
course I got accused of Parental
alienation myself all the time no such
thing happened
I was always very positive about
my ex-wife
about his mother but he clearly said
that he said it and he repeated it
several times
and we thought well
you know we need to alert people of this
and we went to the school because
they're all other at the time all other
it was getting late no one else was
answering the phone we thought we've got
to take him to the school and discuss
this while he's still in the mood for
talking
and then I was basically accused of
making him say it
so you can't win either way can you that
he was saying this but nobody wanted to
listen and it must be somehow my fault
that he's saying this
and then a few days later like I said on
the day the coroner made the finding so
the
the local Authority applied to
have him in take him into care they had
coerced him in my opinion
to say that he was scared of both his
parents mother and father
right am I
now who knows what the truth is
but obviously his best friend had been
murdered by
you know there's all sorts of
things going on there in his mind
um
I have hundreds of photos we have very
happy reminisce reminiscences
of my time with him during 2019
several Witness
accounts saying how happy he was in my
my
and he was taken into care and
that's when the public law
the public law process
started
so they took him into foster care that's
right so now he's not with you or your
ex-wife he's not with either of us no
okay and that was 2020
so this is the end of yeah the beginning
of 2020 at the end of 2019.
repair so 2019 2020
and
that was because
he he said something to them that made
them want to take him into care or yes
that seems to be enough okay okay and
the the judge who is an even more a new
judge was appointed
uh judge
her on the judge Dowdy now it seems that
she had um
she stated that
a threshold of abuse had been crossed
now I have no idea what that meant at
the time I have no idea what that means
no it seems to be completely arbitrary
this kind of Declaration made that yet
that threshold's been crossed you can
take it but in family court you don't
actually need evidence is the issue no
evidence was presented
um we had
a psychologist a psychologist had been
involved in the private law
uh proceedings his findings were kind of
rubbished
by most of the illegal professionals at
the time so it didn't really have much
bearing on the case
however a new psychologist was employed
to analyze
all three of us meet my ex-wife and my
son
but this takes a month you know that the
wheels turn very slowly
so where are we up to 2020
and
I'm allowed to see my son once every now
and then
but there are more and more restrictions
imposed by local Authority
so
you know
um
are you not allowed to say you love him
right you're not allowed to ask him
where he's been you're not allowed to
say where you've been you're not allowed
to tell them what you've been doing
you don't like to touch him you're not
allowed to your own son yeah see well
what happened
what happened we the start of this
process actually very happy I'm just I'm
so confused because it's like okay so
you get
they take your son into care and you're
not allowed to talk to your son and Care
is that what I'm understanding
well it it was a it was a process that
developed over the the months so I was I
was seeing him once every three four
four three or four weeks it was a bit
well he doesn't care yes so it was a bit
like where is he staying with another
family another family in incense Rapture
yes okay and what was that a good family
at least was it you think I have no idea
but they're strangers essentially yeah
so now he's staying with strangers and
you're not allowed to ask him how he's
doing you're not a lot which is crazy
because
like what if it's a bad family what was
it yeah but you don't even know because
you can't like you can't even ask your
son how he's doing no and this is
essentially because they accused both of
you of abuse now
or the threshold yes
they but this is where it gets smoking
to this day I'm not really sure how are
you not sure there's no court documents
I can show you a court order can I see
yeah
ecologist was pretty darning of myself
and that is the
look this psychologist was
employed
to seek the truth
I suggested it it was my idea okay it
came from my legal team that we want
another psychologist report someone
who's really going to get to the bottom
of this once and for all
because this is obvious and and at
various times
remember no no fact-finding hearing had
been attempted up to this point a no
fact finding ever been attempted to this
day no fact-finding hearing okay okay so
there's never been a process of
witnesses and cross-examination that
sort of thing
it's never actually happened
so we've got
so um sorry
sir
there's just there's so many people
involved in this that it's just it's
getting a bit confusing I'm sorry yes no
which which I mean it's it's seven years
so it's kind of hard to condense but but
essentially so you're
your legal team is idea is the
psychologist but the psychologist comes
in and gives like a very biased it's a
hatchet job I think would be a hatchet
job yeah is there any can I see it how
do I yes you it's on here again okay
well I will certainly show you okay so
I've had a subsequent psychologist
report done on myself uh which shows and
is the psychologist employed by the
government yes okay so this was funded
by the local Authority okay but you did
a private psychologist and then that was
all clear yeah but the one that came
from the government basically said you
were both incapable of being parents and
that's how your son got put into care
yeah but
what actually happened was the
psychologist took everything my ex-wife
said as gospel truth so he didn't
question any of her allegations so it's
the same old thing did she file a
criminal report no okay because that's
the biggest that's what I've learned is
you have to ask them what court they
filed in criminal or family because
family court it seems like everything
goes but Criminal Court like they
actually need evidence yeah well it's my
understanding is that in a criminal
court the the test is beyond Reasonable
Doubt
so you'll find guilty of a crime if you
are found you know if it is beyond
reasonable doubt that you committed that
crime but in Family Court
the rule is balance of probabilities
so is the man likely to be abusive is
the woman likely to be saying the truth
well it becomes incredibly subjective
oh and be that's subjective and it's
going to be based on your world view
cool so if you if you've been if you
have a feminist world view you already
hate man and a lot of people from these
government institutions have a feminist
like lens on the world absolutely yeah I
I I have met very few professionals
who I wouldn't
automatically
tell was a feminist even even many of
the males were clearly feminist in their
in their Outlook the psychologist was a
male
but he told the feminist lie
and he used all the latest buzzwords so
I'm I have narcissistic tendencies
and you will find
the word narcissism
used time and again
to describe men
that they can't really find anything
else wrong with okay because they've got
no evidence that they found I've done
nothing wrong they've got no
there's no instance of abuse even
the local Authority didn't even accuse
me of any particular instance of abuse
so there's no allegations made Against
Me by the local Authority themselves
but I have some narcissistic tendencies
right that'll do
you can't possibly be a good father
because he's
he cares too much about his son you know
he sees his son as a as an extension of
himself which I do okay he expects a lot
from his son he's pushed yes I'm pushing
I'm strict disciplinary no I'm not
actually but two of the two other three
is enough for that okay
so once you're branded a narcissist
it's a it's a wonderful
you can't fight back because whenever
you say actually I'm not a narcissist
well you would say that wouldn't you
because you're a narcissist so I'm
you know I when I say well sorry I'm not
a thug I'm not the person you think I am
I'm a chartered engineer
always thinks he's a genius
right he's got an IQ of 120 but he says
he's a genius which requires 121. you
think well this is ridiculous I never
claimed I was I just I'm just not a thug
where did the lawyers fall into this
they they capitulated at every right my
own
sorry gave up without a fight at every
opportunity so I did better representing
myself
not having a clue while I I made
progress in the private law why
because I think
they knew the rules of the game they
knew that well you're a man
and there's a woman who just will not
relent she's implacably hostile
it's another buzzword
and they just will not question the
woman they cannot
they want questions they won't do it the
lawyers won't even question the lawyers
but I'm confused because I'm supposed to
interview a law firm soon well I think I
think they're second guessing now that
they've seen my channel but but but they
said because I I spoke to like the woman
who owns it and she was telling me that
a lot of the men don't listen to advice
and this this is just what they're
saying right and they're also they also
say that
um they don't have of course like of
course they're gonna help the men like
they don't have any incentive not to
they only get paid
but if we help them and that's how we
get clients okay so my question like why
would they not give you good advice
because they could see the writing on
the wall because they know that they
know how these
they know how these cases play out
they yes they did give a lot of advice
they advised me to
quite frequently accept responsibility
for things that I was
accused of uh
uh I have
I have this old-fashioned thing called
Integrity right
and it's it's a bugger sometimes because
they want you to say
put your hand up oh it was it was me oh
I'm gonna I'm going to meet you halfway
on this I'm going to meet you halfway on
that
but
if you have integrity you understand
that this truth
and untruth right and I'm going to say
what is true
I'm not going to start
down that slippery slope of saying
yeah it's partly my fault I I'll go part
the way but not you know because
because you just know it's going to get
even worse if you accept some liability
then they want you to accept more more
and more and more until
until
and and they were the ones that told you
to get the psychologist
yes that eventually that led to your son
being put into care a lot of the problem
is that when we talk about teams of
solicitors barristers lawyers
that you're probably imagining
kind of Monolithic group of people that
follow me around throughout the
proceedings right that started seven
years ago and I'm still in contact with
her no there's a different
different one parachuted in every time
so I never really got to
build a relationship with any solicitor
or any Barrister at all and that was
difficult it was challenging because
whenever a barrister would walk through
you think and they've got their little
A4 piece of paper all right okay well
you've got to
um you've got to admit this this and
this
um we don't there's no point in a
fact-finding hearing because there's no
point and he will hang on we want I want
a fact finding him because I want the
truth the truth to be out so some
barristers would say yes we want a fact
finding hearing the next one would come
and say no we don't then the next one
would say we do and I'm left thinking
I don't know so the final order kind of
reflects the confusion and what it
needed really was a judge to to take
control of it and to do what needed to
be done the judge wasn't willing to do
that just playing the game
Okay so
and has there been any progress since
your son was put into foster care
no well
do you you haven't seen him since he's
been in foster care I haven't seen him
for two and a half years no
um
the way it is
look there's another family
okay there's another family I I won't
mention their names
I won't mention the names because they
are as far as I'm aware going through
the process as well now
when Archie
died was murdered
um
my son
in time became
best friends with another young lad okay
now this young Lads was
he was lovely he was um came from quite
an upper class family and uh
you know in this country we have we have
classes and it's probably more obvious
where I live really that's not to say
classes don't mix especially in rural
areas a very small community
one primary school that sort of thing
so but these were kind of seen as very
respectable people pillars of the
community you would say
um
even in debrette's nobility and all that
sort of thing right so it's exactly saw
the person you'd want your son to make
friends with right
and
so they they used to play
the army games that me and my son played
and all that sort of thing and
I used to converse with the father who
because I was being told I'd be told a
lot of [__] behind by the local
Authority by the school I I know
I didn't trust what they had to say
because they'd always say oh yeah he's
doing well now he's doing far better now
without you Mr Jones because he's in
he's in care and we can do with a state
right so we can do everything we're
perfect
and
yeah so much progress has been made
apparently but this the father of this
this little boy knew better because he
was involved he got to see my son
because play dates and that sort of
thing so I was getting a very different
picture painted
by him uh while I was getting back from
local Authority was well your son
doesn't want to see you eventually
he's scared of you
um he hated playing the games he used to
play by the way
um
he only went camping he only played
Soldiers with you because he was scared
of you
and
this this other father said well this is
rubbish your son goes on about you all
the time he worships you
he plays all the same games with
with his boy
um and the police are telling you that
or the school
they occasionally give me
updates but really the social services
do not want to engage with me at all
after he's in care it's all very
reluctant and I really want to end all
meetings and they eventually what we
have is this this one meeting between me
and Casual we'd have several previous
which are very successful
but me
myself edit my edit his name my son
has said that uh
well me and my son sorry me and my son
had a very rough and tumble relationship
let's say our play was Hands-On Rough
and Tumble
and um
this didn't go down so well with some of
the older
more you know more traditional social
workers let's say they saw physical
contact as abuse no but voice play
you know this I know this yeah we are
talking about the parallel world is it
mostly women
yeah it's all women yeah these these
people who are supervising my contact
with my son okay
so my son loved playing soldiers and
this is one particular game
we played rugby and all sorts of
wrestling arm wrestling
even
sparring with the Box boxing gloves and
uh
but is this one game he used to play
used to be the sergeant major
so right Daddy Stand to attention right
and he'd give me I had to March around
stand up straight
and I had to stand up straight do
whatever
and he kind of punched me in the stomach
I'll pull that stomach in all right
chest out
and
and they interjected and said oh you
can't do that you you know and
you can't allow your son to punch if you
have to
you have to create boundaries and I said
look you didn't punch me did he this was
this criticism was going on right in
front of my son so my son was sat and
was sat there this woman was starting to
criticize my
my lack of ability to maintain
discipline okay and I said right in
front of my son so she's undermining me
straight away and I said look
I know very well the difference between
play
and aggression and this is innocent play
no no I don't see that I don't see that
so can we move away from the car so
we're out of earshot and that that took
some time by that point she'd already
undermined all my authority
she started criticizing everything I
started doing and I said look this is
ridiculous you can't we my son had fun
this did you not see the smile on his
face and that was during like one of the
visitations that was supervised this was
the last one we had the last one and
this is before he was in foster care
this is after this is during this during
foster care and and this is basically
two and a half years ago and there's
about one fleeting meeting since but
this I I took exception to this and I
made a complaint I said look
me and my son have to have quality time
together
we have to play the games he wants to
play this was his idea to play this game
they they returned with a list of
Demands saying well you can't you can't
touch your son you can't play physical
games you can't accept violence of any
sort
you can't as I said before you can't say
you'd love him you can't say where have
you been you can't and I'm supposed to
tick this box so the government is
basically telling you you can't even ask
about your son you can't play with your
son you can't tell him you love him
that's right and this is the from the
social worker yes social services are
telling me that I can't do I can't have
a relationship with my son so I refuse
that I understand how these
organizations like work together because
it's just it's weird to me that like
they're all separate organizations but
they're doing the same thing yes that's
right but but it's made up of
individuals so there aren't individuals
that come forward and say this is messed
up like you know what I mean if you have
20 random people that join an
organization wouldn't you think that
some would say this is crazy yes yes I
have I'll have the ideal
example of this that we had several
social workers female
not to cast aspersions but these are
self-selecting people they see
themselves on crusades
uh oh right they bought the people that
go into these careers they see
themselves as like saviors basically yes
at the lower level definitely and
look I have encountered a lot of
incompetence
right and I think most of
it's tempting to see some sort of
overarching conspiracy right because you
think how on Earth has all this happened
right who's the who's a puppet master
here
I'm inclined to think it's just base
stupidity 99 times out of 100. but these
people are self-selecting they go into
these uh professions
with a mission to save poor innocent
females right they're feminists
themselves
so you encounter the the same arguments
and
we say you know Social Services kafkas
are different well they're not different
they they select this from the same pool
of people okay because that was my
question because the organizations
there's
Social Services
and Cask Cafe how are those two related
or they're not related well strictly
speaking they are separate okay
but but they're both government
organizations yes very much so okay so
the government pays
social services and kafkas that's right
okay and then Social Services they're
the ones that took your son away yes
okay and they're the ones that employed
the psychologist it was a social
services psychologist yes okay yeah okay
just make sure
okay and the the court system is
separate or are they where where do they
come uh they are supposedly separate I
mean there are several different layers
of government that you've missed out but
essentially it's all the state isn't it
so you have local government and you
have national government and kafkas so
social services are employed by the
local Authority kafkas okay so they're
the police
is that the local authorities at the
police look no the locals I was in the
County Council that we'd have so
Shropshire Council
it's a strange thing that I've so
they're the people that basically do
planning permission for houses that fill
in potholes that empty the bins that do
and then they they take your child from
you as well I don't see how those
they're not they don't really
but so this is local government is under
social services and then the
psychologist CAF Cass is one thing
the Judiciary would be kind of oh so
this is the judges yeah officially
separate
officially yeah okay and so I'm just
trying to I want to get everybody that's
involved that's been involved in taking
your son away so the government the
County Council Social Services employed
the psychologist and that's how your son
was taken yes then there's the judges
and the lawyers are separate too yes
okay so the lawyers are separate
but the lawyers are private or they also
well
yes they're all private but but some
will be uh
on a contract to deliver uh legal aid so
that so they they will be
funded by the government okay that's
what I thought because their number one
clients are usually the women from the
shelters right that's right because the
government gives them money that's right
for the abuse okay I've heard exactly
what's happened okay and then the judges
um
that's what I want to go back sorry I
just this is there's so many different
pieces it's a bit I won't do this with
you so
and where do the teachers fall in well
they aren't employed by the County
Council as well I suppose okay so the
teachers are also
okay
calf Cass okay and calf Cass was though
just go back to
the calf caps was the one
that they did the report they did it
some yes they did many different reports
about to say
okay
but they're also employed they're
employed by the court
by the judges the judges goes to Cafe
they do yeah they have a close link
they're the court advisory service
because
um judges and magistrates can't be
expected to be experts in every
every aspect of child law and and I
think the Kafka as seen as the eyes and
ears of the judge really
oh so the calf Cass is seen as the eyes
and the ears of the judge but these
again the people that go into these
fields tend to be have a feminist
ideology I would say so yeah yeah
and that's common across the board
okay
so
and calf Cass was the one who was warned
about Archies I I warned a a certain
kaf gas officer yes about
I I didn't warn about that Archer was
going to be murdered
I warned them that there was a hysteria
happening within a group of mothers
uh that could lead
to
uh you know something something Snappy I
think with my my work but I I know that
separately Matthew Spriggs are
definitely warned kafkas and the local
Authority separately okay
about that
okay
and you haven't seen your son since no
well what's happened now is that um and
he's 13 now he's 13. the last time you
saw him he was 11 yeah
wow yeah it's really really painful for
everybody involved
um
I've not given up of course I have um
so what happened was uh I
I approach my local MP Daniel kevchinski
um
Member of Parliament
okay right
would he be above the judges or where
does he fall
yeah he's part not really part of the
government but he sits in the House of
Commons
in Parliament what I say his name again
Daniel kavchinski okay k-a-w
c z y
n s k i okay
okay and what did he say well he you
know I had a meeting with him he was I
gave him the story and uh he was utterly
appalled and um
apparently he's been through a similar
experience himself
uh I don't know all the ins and outs but
um
it seemed to resonate with him
so he he has encouraged the local
Authority
County Council to
instigate a
statutory complaints procedure
essentially invest in investigation an
independent investigation into what's
going on
um and why this has all happened
and
so this is a three-part complaint
procedure
I'm at stage two
stage two is supposed to take no more
than three months so this was a
an investigator was employed by the
council themselves so let's not pretend
she was all that independent right but
she did seem to sympathize with my cause
and she has I understand being very
rigorous in her investigation however
this is supposed to take no more than
three months we are now two years into
this investigation wow this was two
years ago yeah
so and what's happening is the County
Council themselves the local Authority
are stymieing the whole process
they are
it's been sat on their desk for over six
months now this report
from this investigator
the Ombudsman office which is like the
the overseeing regulator
has found in my favor and find them
a token amount
but really
you know in the words of the ombudsman
office
it's a pretty sure sign there's
something wrong if they're not releasing
this report after two years
so I can't really Pro proceed until they
made a report
and there's nothing they won't release
it yeah is it ever do they have any
timeline they've been given
um a
a deadline by the ombudsman's office
which expired two weeks ago
wow okay
right so they are not engaging with me
in any way shape and form
I have an ongoing complaint with the uh
The Institute of psychologists forgive
forgive me I forget their exact title
that's been going on for some six months
Joe inspires that the psychologist in
question
um did not follow the
the practice guidelines
so basically he didn't ask me any
psychological questions
I'm not joking when if I were to say
that his intern and his recent graduate
interviewed me for three hours
and asked me all the psychology
psychological questions
I had a brief Skype call with him
and he didn't ask me anything at all he
just told me what his
place in the process was
and I was asking him what what do you
think the problem is
and
well it's not for me to say
but what are we doing this for you know
why are you what's it for it just seems
to be just another
instrument against fathers really really
another way to
call him a narcissist
that'll do it
we've got nothing else on if you call
him a narcissist yeah
that'll do we can get rid of him then
so that's where I'm at now so you're
still waiting for the report two years
on yeah
two years wow and I've not seen my son
at all in that and I have no idea what
my son's doing
sure
who are can you go through the names
again that you said earlier of like
like could I interview some of the
people in this would they take an
interview I diet it I diet it um
it is a shame that
look I've got to be honest that's
the the two other fathers that I've
mentioned
I've been so psychologically traumatized
in my opinion that they are
Matthew Spriggs is not keen on me
telling my story and I'm not entirely
sure why you will have seen his video on
YouTube but he is very much
he wants to
he wants to defend the memory of his son
so I think he'd like people to stop
talking about him and I get that
but I'm afraid I can't keep quiet
because I have my own son I have my own
story to tell and I know that what
Matthew Spriggs has been through
um and I has been appalling and it needs
more recognition his story is out there
people can read a story they can see his
his YouTube video
the other father
I mentioned
I would say he's gone mad
because what I didn't mention about him
was that his
spouse
also started making false allegations
against him
and my son's other best friend was taken
into care
wow
yeah so you know you've got
rather a lot of children being taken
into care
simply because Archie Spriggs happened
so it's
so
so the Shropshire Corner John Ellery
makes this recommendation
the
more
early intervention needs to be made so
private sector what will we do in the
private sector if someone had completely
failed miserably
I'd let this go
had failed uh
Duty utterly
would we say we'll have a lot more of
that please
oh did we get rid of
get rid of her that's what I would do
but Mr John Ellery
probably with the best of intentions
has made this recommendation
the the answer to the state going wrong
is more State please more State
intervention into people's lives
and
my son was not given to me by the state
the state wasn't there when he was born
when he was conceived
right this is I'm not a religious man
but this is a duty given to me by God
the
he is my son he is my responsibility I
have done nothing wrong I understand the
state is there to prevent tragedies
a safety net is needed clearly
but the answer to getting it completely
wrong with Archie Spriggs is to ruin
everybody else's life
any child that came near to that or
anything relating to this group of women
perhaps
maybe they are taking my
my observation seriously now now it's
too late
but they've gone from one extreme to The
Other Extreme and the right answer is
somewhere in the middle isn't it
so
the state
and their
you know
it's just has no space it's the state
can get out of my son's life right
because my son is so traumatized it
seems I don't know what to believe but
my son it seems hates everything he ever
knew that they have tried to delete his
life
what a happy life he had the first six
years of his life were just magic
he had a wonderful time with me as well
he had a wonderful time with his mother
let's let's not pretend that
she was always a monster she had some
good features she was a great mother
but something happened to her
so you know
this this is a
this is what it is to be to be British
in in this day and age
the
yeah we live
by the states leave
we don't we don't have a freedom we
don't have
Magna Carta it's what's that trial by
a jury of 12 peers you know
these are just people making arbitrary
decisions a judge
who is she where does she come from
you know you go through her her findings
and you just don't
there's no sense there's no
people always ask me why is your son in
care
I have no idea
I can't tell you
you can read all the documents
and I would welcome if anybody could
explain to me certainly none of the
social workers can explain
I had one social worker called
Gareth Edwards
the only male social worker I really had
involved his words to me were Mr Jones
your son shouldn't be in care you should
be back with his family
I said Thank God someone who knows
someone who gets it like you said
earlier saw it as someone who gets it
right and there are on occasion
people that seem to listen seem to
understand
and he said well you know we're doing
all this um therapy for your son none of
it seems to be working he won't say
anything bad against you
you can see what kind of therapy they're
doing you know
has dad daddy ever hit you daddy ever
touched you daddy ever you know wow we
know we know this has happened it's
obvious they want
they want the dirt on me okay
and they don't have any
and he said well they're going to change
tact they're going to
you know
do something different
and he started to make progress
and after a while it seemed that this
progress was suppressed and he himself
said Mr Jones I'm being very closely
supervised
so I can't do what I want to do
some weeks later he left
so
someone with some integrity was there
but he could see that it was harming his
humming his child his job his career he
didn't want any part of it he had a
salary a mortgage he had a family to
look after I can't blame him really
I
but there just isn't enough people there
isn't it needs to reach a critical mass
one person and a sea of these kind of
do-gooders
you know
the these kind of
sycophants could call them isn't enough
so we just get the same old
oh she's made allegations again to this
day I will ask
you know why is my son in care oh well
allegations have been made Mr Jones
seven years on
all right
she didn't think to look at these
alligators still peddling the same old
rubbish the allegations were made you're
just going to accept what you said seven
years on at what point do you start to
look at
what actually happened the mechanics of
this why my son may be saying what he's
saying why is he saying he's scared of
me when we've got all this evidence why
is he saying he's scared of his mother
he loved his mother
where does this come from does it come
from the foster parents does it come
from social workers themselves is it
coming from this because this doesn't
add up you're supposed to be making
things better
but you're just making things worse and
worse and worse
and my son is becoming a lost cause
we all know what happens to children
without
parents right
you know what's going to happen to him
when he's 18.
is he going to
you know his foster carers have been
paid to look after him
he's a great he's a good little boy he
doesn't cause trouble so of course I'm a
nice little learner
it's exactly the job they want
but when that money Runs Out are they
going to support him through University
are they going to get him his first job
are they going to build a family
business with him no he's going to be
out in the street
and that
you know my son is everything to me I
live for my son everything I've done
I started my own company for my to give
me a chance to look after my son right
a family business I have a family
business without a family right
I stayed I bought a house there I stayed
in the area I want to run away I want to
get away from this right I want
you know I come close to suicide
very often right I still think it's a
likely outcome that I will once every
Avenue's been
been explored
every dead end is reached uh I will
probably end it
because you can't live with this pain
indefinitely it doesn't go away
and you can't make people listen to you
whatever you say
you're a narcissist you're an abuser
you're a denier
you know are you denied
your abuse because I denied abuse it
didn't happen no but you're a denier
what answer is that it's like some sort
of
communist show trial isn't it you just
don't there's no way through that that
barrier whatever you say
there is always a something coming back
you say I'm not a thug are you a
narcissist then
if I'm stupid because they want me to be
stupid
and I'm not stupid
I'm not
I'm not incapable
I say I'm a great dad because I am a
great dad and I get criticized for
saying it because
you'll read you know the judge herself
said what father would claim to be a
great dad
or maybe fathers who are great dads
they don't exist in her world they're
all supposed to take responsibility and
accept
liability for abuse even though it
didn't happen
so what impact do you think this is
having on your son
catastrophic
another cat
astrophic
I wish I knew the truth I I had Snippets
from his friend's dad
the harm that we that he was becoming
withdrawn even though the Social
Services said otherwise I was getting
the truth
apparently it's all my fault though
my son blames me for all for being in
care
that's the story going around but
he was taken from
his mother because I wanted it
now I don't want him to be taken from
his mother
I wanted his mother to
wake up
take the Olive Branch
be the mother you used to be
what is stopping you what is this for
who wins
what do you think
is the outcome of this
so she's
just as childless as me and it doesn't
seem to bother her
well she she doesn't get to see your son
either
I'm not sure
if I'm completely honest I'm not sure
but she's certainly not looking after
him
but my son
my son was traumatized yeah
of course he was traumatized
but they've got completely the wrong
reason he was traumatized apparently
because he was abused by his parents
he was traumatized because his parents
split up
his
his enduring wish was that mummy and
daddy could be friends and get back
together
that's
that's what upset it
not this imaginary abuse
not Daddy used to punch him up
because it didn't happen
and now
oh look I can only put myself in his
shoes in this position I think back too
the child I was at that age
quite pretty quiet
pretty reserved shy
are you scared of most things really
and I put myself in his situation
it's a fate worse than death really I
can't imagine
me being without my mum and dad when I
was age
they were kind they were kind of
everything to me
and I'm sure
his parents are everything to him
what do you say to
there's a lot of people that I talk to
about these issues and their responses
that the dads don't fight hard enough
look I completely understand why
a lot of fathers run away
because the pain
that the pain is Indescribable to lose
your child now we hear a lot about
mothers losing children becoming
hysterical
and we understand it in mothers but we
don't understand it within fathers
I can only speak for myself
and say that
there have been times where I have just
wanted to run away I've seen the
right
ridiculous I've seen the war in Ukraine
I thought why don't just volunteer
why don't I just get blown up and
just end my life in some sort of
glorious way or some some something I
didn't get to go to Afghanistan I didn't
get to do that
but it's you know
I bought a motorbike
about 10 I bought two
and
you get on your motorbike and you just
go
and you go and you go and you find
yourself Atop The Shetland Islands
and
I didn't
doesn't matter how fast you go
he's he's always with you he's always
he's always holding my heart
he's always saying
he's always saying I love you Daddy
no you just wanna
blank of the images at your head's off
so
I'm going to forgive most fathers who
give up because the hopelessness is real
there is no way through the [__]
there is no way of getting your job back
you're probably as well to
give up
or kill yourself
because you're not going to be a father
again
that's
right
I've seen what I've seen a stereot I've
seen The Madness of women
I've seen
I've seen into the face of evil he knows
we've seen it to the face of evil yeah
just
it's
you know to murder a child
and the man had no say
it was just one call
and the fathers had no say in anything
there's no
they're not gonna listen they won't
listen
but you know you've got
evil exists in two places
it exists in Leslie's speed
but it exists
in the apathy of these people
that it just
self-perpetuates that nobody
will stick the head above the parapet
and I think evil is is
you know can we say it's
you know Hitler was evil enough right
but there was an evil in the apathy
of the people who allowed that
to happen evil happens when good people
do nothing right
and that's where we are with
family
Court
family law there's a lot of people doing
nothing and allowing this and saying
well that's a shame isn't it
or we are where we are how many times
have I heard that
we are where we are
doesn't mean a damn thing does it
that's what they tell you and these
concerns yeah we are where we are yeah
where we are I said well you're going to
address any of this
you're going to understand this you're
gonna
they look at they look at this they
don't understand it they don't have the
time to go through
you know you see how many hours it takes
to
we've scratched the surface here
and they don't have time for that you
know where they are where they are just
a process to them
they don't understand there's a little
boy there
lost his parents
there's other boys you know
have their family ripped apart
so yeah that's that's what I think
how common do you think this is
very common
um
it's common in rushbury so it's rupture
I can tell you that
tiny little village maybe a few hundred
people in the village
but look I've read you might want to
read
um Vincent McGovern's book
the Warren
forgive me the Warren fathers I think
it's cool I read that recently
um
you might want to interview him I don't
know but I did read this book I'm hoping
to get more involved into this
activist kind of scene
um
I I'm not either I'm not sure how much
talent I've got for it but I will try my
best
because more people need to speak go
more people need to take the risk
and
look I've written a book
um first draft form
but uh really Vincent McGovern's book is
the one you want if you want facts and
Figures it's very analytical it's the
book I would probably have written as a
chartered engineer but he got there
first the book I've read is far more
personal emotional
anecdotal
um and he just paints a picture of
I got it
he's got it right
he understands it and the pictures he
paints of these people are right on the
nail
and it's uh you know he was based in
London
um he's uh there are several Charities
but look these charities
don't get anything like the funding of
the female the women's Aid and the
children right sort of thing make a
government funding
hundreds of Millions
do you think women's Aid brainwashes
women yes
because that's my and I want to see if
there's a way
that I can like join like I wanted to
see if I went into women's Aid no
because I was thinking like if I could
use like my middle name is what I use
for my channel so they wouldn't know my
first you know what I'm saying and if
like you just accused someone random
like just to record it and show like I
didn't know what the process would be
like to do that I I obviously never
attended a women's Aid meeting uh but
I know the rhetoric used
I know my ex-wife the words that she
used cannot she was a Polish speaker you
know
but the words you know Survivor right
Jesus Survivor everyone's a Survivor
denier right
abuser
my wife never said these words before we
used to make fun of this right
I I could you not in the early days
really you know it she used to
she used to really hate women that that
did this sort of thing no way I'm kid
you not she saw herself as
middle class professionals you know
successful whatever
uh which which we probably weren't in
all fairness but you know we had
aspirations we saw ourselves as
respectful people and she used to mock
them said
you know we would say you know
domestic abuse never hurt anyone you
know kind of just they've just left a
sense of humor everything about it you
know
um but to see her use this language
he said well this is this ain't no
other women using exactly the same
language all over the all over the place
and these are great terms you know
denier
how would you combat that how do you
combat being a denial denier as if that
that is of the ultimate insult you're a
denier
yeah I am a dinner because it didn't
happen right
so it's so weird so she literally made
fun of girls that did this yes
yes you did wow she she hated uh this
Emily s sorry assembly s character who
um
who did this to her own family she
thought it was appalling
and then she did it herself
I don't I don't understand it there's a
there's a process of
something happened in her yeah
okay our relationship was going sour
but
but we were friends and we surely that's
so weird you know
that's so weird
okay I just wonder like what
what switched
look two psychologists can't tell you
well they don't want to tell you
something's wrong
something's wrong but they don't have a
word for it that
you know
impact of implacable hostility
several syndromes
from a psychological
it's another thing I should mention
parental alienation is a biggie
but
I was told very clearly parental
alienation doesn't exist
local Authority in the social services
told me out right in fact it was Gareth
Edwards The Helpful one said well though
our certain there are certain people
in the local Authority who say that
parental alienation doesn't exist he was
being very helpful and he was saying to
me well the message I received was well
his boss says this doesn't exist so it
doesn't exist
right so women there's never been a
woman on the face of the planet whoever
tried to turn a child against their
father or vice versa
you can just dismiss it I know someone
that happened too it was like her
her parent dad was always in Afghanistan
or something like he was out and she
would always like the mom would always
say really bad things about the dad and
I remember being like younger
um
thinking that her mother was crazy like
I remember like being you know like a
kid and my mom always said that her mom
was nuts yeah and then one day
um it's like the kids they're not stupid
no like one day they grow up and they
figure out like all these women that do
that like one day you grow up and your
kids aren't dumb they figure it out no
no of course and there's a whole
generation of kids who have essentially
been like lied to by their mothers where
I really don't even believe in deadbeat
dads anymore I think that's like I don't
really think that's as common as they
push I haven't seen many I I don't know
any but I can I can think of many people
that have been estranged from their kid
I don't know a single one that doesn't
want to be in their kids lives yeah yeah
absolutely that's um and that's been my
there's so few statistics on this
because obviously statistics are funded
takes money right
well that's the problem is all these
people they want studies because I I
talk like the laughter like people on
the opposite side and they want studies
to show this stuff and you can easily
find some numbers that back you up like
when it comes to men getting custody of
their kid the fact that it's like 10 20
it's crazy it's negligible it's 50 it's
DNA I don't know why it's not 50 custody
it's like actually mad seems obvious to
me but
and it's really sad because like even
just hearing you I can hear how
distraught you are
like I can I can I can like see it in
your voice this has been this is taking
you over the last like decade yes it's
ruined our lives and you'll you'll never
get that time back
my mother is in the worst state than I
am your mom is yeah she's a 79 year old
woman and
you know it's
um just
to see how close they were
my mom and my son
her only grandchild
and
just that her
you know to see how she's been pursued
by police
for simply approaching the school and
trying to trying to waver right
and he waves back and he's got a big
beaming smile because he loves his
grandma
the police said that she can't wave at
him
what was his yeah the police have
approached him a number of times
stay away well where is the where is the
court order against my mother all right
this is this is the point that
simple logic dictates right you can
throw whatever crap you like against me
you can call me a narcissist you call me
a deny you call me an abuser right you
can deny
my relationship with my son
but how does that
how does that relate to my mother
was she an abuser was she a narcissist a
sheer denier as well
no right so why doesn't she get to see
what what is this unspoken doesn't say
that in any of the legal
anywhere but no
can't have a relationship with your
grandchild well and and now he's growing
up with strangers and we all know those
horror stories and foster care so you
don't even know what's like going on
with him uh a panorama program BBC
primary I'm no fan of the BBC by the way
but
they did do a
Panorama program on herefordshire Social
Services of when would this be about a
year ago
and um yeah Heritage interrupts your
neighboring so you you kind of think
well if that's happening there it's
happening here right
very similar rural County
and
it's just horrific stories you know
children being taken away from families
for no reason
put with
Foster carers were in one instance
pedophiles living in a static caravan
so how does that how does a decision
like that get married
and
I don't think shropshire's any better
and I don't think we can say oh it's all
there if everything else is Rosy they
said themselves that they've heard
countless stories from
all over the country
and you've got my story and you've
you know there are many others and I you
know
conspiracy theories
probably not right probably just
stupidity probably just the culture
because we talk about independent you
know you draw your diagram
and we say this is independent from that
and that that's independent even they
they're laughingly claim to have the
independent reviewing officer
in my son's case well
you think independent reviewing also
excellent go to and go to her to
for questions right for answers
she sits in the same office
as a social service as a social worker
she's overlooking where's the
independence so they call her
independent
but it's just it's just a word it's just
they oh it's been independently verified
by the person on the same payroll
as a social worker she's uh so they work
together a lot of these like independent
agencies I saw it all the time most of
the judicial processes are not in a wink
um
I know that
one of the reasons I overheard a
conversation
there's kafkas officer was talking to
the social worker
and essentially it
it went along the lines of
this has been going on too long we've
had enough
we want to move on
we want a we want a different judge a
stronger judge who's going to make a
decision
think well okay you've had enough what
about my son has he had enough of this
process yet
is he not the focus of all this does it
heart will it harm him if it goes on for
a few more years and we might get a
result or you say I've had enough let's
just throw it in the bin
and move on to the next but some of
these
do they ever do interviews
like if they thought they thought it was
a feminist organism
is an interview
I don't know I don't know I'm
I'm not the person to ask really I think
Vincent McGovern might
you might want to approach him
because his book was
pretty good no I'm just thinking like
it'd be good to get
get someone like on the inside just to
like see
because
even if it's not me like I know girls
that could do the same thing that would
I think I think it would be a
sure if I hit
really yeah because they're not going to
they're not going to question a dumb
thing you say
right
so it's like if I went and made up a
whole story just to see how far I could
take it and they will give you the tools
you're a Survivor and these are the
tools to survive right this is this is
what this is the pattern of behavior
you know do you recognize this pattern
of behavior in your ex-husband you know
did he used to
did he used to argue
yeah well he's an abuser did he used to
take responsibility for financial
matters he's a financial controller
did he used to get upset when you went
out on Late Night
drinking binges yes he's a coercive
control you know that's the other thing
but they've got an answer for everything
unwilling to bet
I know I've heard the same story from
other guys too yeah yeah where it's like
they go to the women's shelters and then
they have stories ready to go based on
your background so these English say
this if he's Nigerian say this yes
yeah well I I'm sure the fact that an
Englishman married to a Polish woman
I think that there are connotations like
I said that an Englishman
oh we can't get an English wife he has
to go to Poland because he wants to
dominate her and all this rubbish the
reason the reason I I was asking about
the Poland is because
again they always say to find a girl
from another culture because it won't
they won't do this type of stuff
um and Poland is actually one of the
reference like countries because they're
Eastern Europe well I think so many
polls uh kind of migrated to this
country a few years ago but um
you know my experience of Polish people
is they tend to stick together you don't
find many Polish people marrying British
people
but um
look I'm not going to start
tiring them all with the same brush I
love Polish people
my son's polish
now I understand
um
wow
I can't believe they placed your child
in care that's so I'm so sorry that
happened to you
thanks that's actually so disgusting
um
like I said I've got plenty of
documentation to show you can I see some
of it
yes about this whole case so what would
happen with that interview uh well it
was
it wasn't as detailed as what we've done
it was about 90 minutes
um just told them the story as I've told
you this was
how long ago was this maybe 80 months
two years ago
um
the BBC correspondent
was
kind of shocked and appalled by by what
I had to say he was very keen to
to uh publish it I thought he was a
radio reporter so it would have been a
radio piece
and then he took it back to the legal
department the legal department said no
this is confidentiality and they might
be found
in contempt of court so they can't do it
and this is why this is why
there are tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands of fathers like me that you'll
never ever this is what it is
secrecy
okay
what I want to do with you
is I actually want to make like a more
in-depth video
if that's if you're comfortable with it
okay that really just specials in on
like your case because I started this
with just like a general documentary
yeah but if you're willing to actually
put the names and stuff out there in the
court documents
it depends how I mean in depth you want
to go I won't be willing to work with
you it's it's it's about
it's about the level of risk that I
don't want to go straight to prison
but so
but I want to I want to tell the story
right so
okay well there's two options that I can
do so because I I'm just thinking I'm
like a creative so
I was almost thinking if I could figure
out how to get and you you can pick
right so I have a general documentary I
think I have the stuff I really need for
the general one yeah so that's just like
about the court system you know I do
they'll edit out like you know these
parts but like and then they'll do maybe
a one-on-one interview we can leave the
names or take them out whatever you want
to do but I think I could actually do a
pretty my thought and I don't you know
I'm new to YouTube I've only it's crazy
but I've only been doing this a year and
a half so but my thought is I really
want to do
I'm trying to get in the system in a way
like to expose it and record it in some
way that that's exactly because as a
woman they're not gonna you they're not
going to know like I can just my my
YouTube I use Pearl that's my middle
name yeah I'm American and I've heard
you don't even need to be a UK citizen
to do this
to do
to like to go into the women's shelter
and stuff my ex was polish yeah yeah so
and if not me like I have girls that I
can just send to do it if it's if it has
to be yes yes
um and so and I'd like to maybe approach
some of the people that are involved in
this case as like I'll use the same
buzzwords as like a feminist
organization yeah does that make sense
yes and so I can even if it's not me I
can send in another girl to do the same
thing and like interview them from like
a feminist point of view
um and I could go really in depth into
this case depending on how in depth you
want to do it but I think this is
actually
things gold Dusty what Gold Dust I don't
know what gold does just very good stuff
no yeah I think it's because most of the
guys it's like they can't put their face
in it they can't like
and I understand why yeah
um well
look
you could think about it it doesn't have
to be yeah I'm gonna have to think about
it a bit I mean my face look
am I expected to pretend my son doesn't
exist
well no my son exists he's my son I will
talk about my son if I want all right
so that there has to be
a level of detail I suspect that we
that we've gotta we've got to put that
threshold in somewhere so we do we put
names in yes or no to put some names in
but not others I suspect that's what
what would be best because Archie
Spriggs that is in the public domain
already
my son is not in a public domain so
maybe
I know this isn't a definitive answer
because I'll go away and think about it
but maybe we should pick and choose
which names we mentioned yeah that's I'm
willing to work with
no I think this is actually like crazy I
still can't believe that some of this
stuff is legal
um and especially knowing that like you
still in care you know if we can help
you in any way like you know
um there's clearly two you know two
reasons why I'm doing this I want my son
back number one obviously but
look if I can help other kids along the
way if I can help to expose like I said
I'd like to become part of the activist
community on this yeah no I think I
think I could make it a really good
documentary and it would be like focused
on you to be honest it would be talking
especially with the Archie part in there
yes
um if you don't want to go with that in
depth I can just use clips from this and
put it in the general one it's up to you
um but yeah you can just think about it
I'll have a think yeah
um
especially if you could get Archie's dad
and I know he's maybe not but sometimes
people come out of the woodwork I know
it's such a shame
um I I had quite a close relationship
with with Matthew and was
with your own uh and with Tim Rafferty
so Tim Rafferty would be the
the
X of Emily ASP and they all had the same
story yeah and I I pushed and pushed I
said look why don't the four of us group
together yeah there's strengths in
numbers here
but
I want you know I'm obviously very very
I feel very sad for Matthew Spriggs I
don't want to encroach him his grief
I've I feel like I've gone
past
the point that he'd want me to go
already
um but there's stuff here in the public
interest
that and obviously in my son's interest
I'm not I'm going to speak up I'm going
to say what I saw
um
Jerome Mason
dod you won't completely party
I don't know what's become of him
yeah if if we want this route it would
be a pretty long project to be honest
because it's going to take time to like
we might do this short one and if we
were to do the long one with you yeah um
like it's going to take time uh okay
okay like because we would have to like
my ideally I'm trying to interview I'm
trying to get interviews with some of
the people in it as much as I can I
would love Matthew speaks to be involved
you did you see his video the YouTube
video no but I'll I'll look at it after
it is very very revealing okay video
um
so
yeah see that have have a hanky spare it
is very very distressing
um
I I think it says a lot really
this out of the shot as well because I'm
going to ask you a couple of times
sorry what were you saying you think
it's really revealing
um
I I think because Matthew Spriggs made a
a YouTube video that
it's
you really need to see that video for
yourself
that was done in collaboration with a
a parental alienation charity I believe
um
as I've said I
I don't speak for Matthew Spriggs there
is unfortunately some tension between us
and I think I've exceeded
the level that he'd want me to go
but um
but this stuff
is is in the public domain already and
it there is a real public interest
issue here the
I was witness to this I saw it from a
from Another Side and my son seems to
have paid the price for it so I'm going
to speak out
right yeah
what would you say to your son
I dream about this every night I always
dream about my son and
I have such fears
such fears that he he doesn't want to
talk to me that he doesn't want to
listen that
he calls me bad names
um he's 13. so he's not the child I used
to know I I imagine that he's developed
and well will want to talk about us
slightly
more adult
at a slightly more adult level
above all I want to tell him the truth
but I have no wish to
have no wish to denigrate his mother
his mother isn't well
and I'd rather see his mother
was
think of her yeah I have sympathy for
her right because this doesn't make
sense that she's destroyed her own
family she's stored her own child
and what the local Authority are not
doing is helping her
and that's really what I've asked for
time and time again is please help her
other than that I mean just the obvious
stuff tell him I love him
I tell him I've never stopped thinking
about him
because I love him completely
and whether it's a narcissistic
parenting style or not he feels like my
right arm yeah
it was tea it was taken from me you know
that I can't operate without
and I see no purpose to my life
without
why are we on why are we on this planet
what is the point
if it is not to bring children into the
world
you know
well thank you so much for coming
um and sharing everything
um
if there's anything we can do to help
you and support you I actually I
actually think it's disgusting what
they've done to you
to my son not to me yeah well it's to
you too true but but you're at your son
above all else it is him that this has
been done to that
I see myself as collateral damage really
yeah it hurts me
and I always talk about being child
focused I know right
we should be child focuses about him but
they don't act like that they say child
focused and it's just a
it's a cliche to that it's really mother
focused
so
I'm a grown man I can take
pain to a degree I can take
the abuse
but my son
my son doesn't deserve any of it
yeah
um
thank you so much for coming I think I
really appreciate you being so
forthcoming with your story
um yeah and let us know if there's any
way we can support you thank you very
much I I will look forward to
a collaboration yeah yeah
um guys
make sure you like the video on your way
out um subscribe to the channel thank
you again for coming
um bring that notification Bell and if
you have any stories that you guys want
to see told on this channel make sure
you email them to me just pearlythings
gmail.com or message me on Instagram
just probably thinks one
um subscribe to the channel we'll talk
to you next time